nice chatting with you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled keynote presentation
expanding access to compassionate
evidence-based treatment for opioid use
disorders this webinar is part of the
opioid crisis event and i'm susie valdez
of labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lab roots so
let's get started before we begin i want
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by communicating with other
attendees using our new live chat
feature during this presentation you can
find that live chat located at the right
of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you want during
this presentation so to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation finally as a
reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits link
located at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen with the navigation bar or from
the lobby i now present today's speaker
dr jennifer sharp potter a vice
president of research interim research
and professor of psychiatry and
behavioral sciences at the university of
texas health sciences center san antonio
for a complete biography of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen dr water welcome you
may now begin your presentation
thanks so much and thanks to lab roots
for inviting me to participate um in
this important topic um i find myself
more and more anytime i get an
opportunity to speak about opioids and
substance use
i try to make it there because i'm just
actually very excited that the
opportunities that is afforded by the
awareness that's growing in the united
states over the past 10 years related to
substance use disorders more broadly
so what i'm going to do today is utilize
some of the work that we've been doing
in texas to tell the story
of
how we can impact
opioid use disorder reduce morbidity and
mortality related to substance use
disorders and a couple things before i
get started what you'll notice is i
sometimes go interchangeably
between substance use disorder and
opioid use disorder and that's really
because
from my perspective we aren't in the
midst of an opioid crisis we're actually
in the midst of a substance use disorder
crisis that results from a lack of
understanding of how to treat opioid use
disorder and generally our country's
discomfort with talking about substance
use in general and so hopefully
my perspective on this will give you
something to think about as we uh go on
with our days
and a little bit maybe that will be
doing you'll be doing a little bit
differently and whatever it is that you
guys do
in your day to day
around substance use
so
my story begins a few years ago i was
trained as a researcher i'm a clinical
psychologist i
have spent most of my career conducting
clinical trials
randomized controlled trials the gold
standard for treatment development both
with behavioral treatments and
medication treatments and some devices
as well
and a number of years ago i realized
that i needed my work to change because
while i
love developing treatments and working
on this aspect what i was realizing was
that there was a significant problem
between what we developed in the
research environment and it actually
translating out into the community in a
way that was meaningful and that would
make impact
and in the face of this staggering
number of deaths and illness associated
with opioid use disorder it was really
hard just to to not take action on that
and as a result of that i started to
have some conversations with
leadership in texas health and human
services which is our state health
agency in texas and i got kind of the
the opportunity of a lifetime to be able
to translate some of the work that my
field of substance use disorder research
does and see whether or not we can
actually deploy this in a thoughtful way
in texas uh to mitigate uh the issues
we've had
related to opioid use and opioid use
disorder so that's my story and i'm
gonna walk you through it and i'm hoping
out of this you'll be able to take
something away of use to you and think a
little bit differently about it
so
i've already made a mistake excuse me
there we go
so the first thing i wanted to let you
know because my story begins with
funding uh like many people i'm only
able to do the work that i'm funded to
do uh and i'm the benefactor of a number
of awards both from as you'll see here
from the national institute on drug
abuse where we do clinical trials
and then also our texas health and human
services contracts um and if you look at
this
normally this would just be an
acknowledgement of my funders
who by the way don't endorse anything
that i'm going to say everything that
i'm saying today is my opinion based on
my experience and expertise
but you'll look at these projects and i
have a number of them from health and
human services and that's typically how
it works right you
go ahead and you look at different
programs and you take advantage of the
funds that are available
but what we're doing in texas right now
is we have an overall framework that
i'll be sharing with you today
and we're really looking at how
utilizing diverse funding we can
actually work towards improving the
system of care for opioid use disorder
and more recently for substance use
disorder in the in the state of texas
and we really believe that
transformational change is possible even
in the face of great challenges
and that we'll be able to reduce
morbidity and mortality related to
opioids and substance use disorders
um
so compassion is a word that gets thrown
around a lot lately
you know people are passionate about
this and they care about compassion and
because it's in the title i thought it
would be useful for me to share what
compassion means to me
um and this is a definition from a
dictionary compassion is to recognize
the suffering of others and then take
action to help or a tangible expression
of love for those who are suffering and
so compassion is really different than
empathy and sometimes we use them
interchangeably
i like to think of compassion as a verb
and i take note of the take action to
help
and so expanding access
means that each of us in our own way has
to take action to help
if we're going to be able to give people
access to the very best care possible we
need to have compassion because that's
that action part of this it's too often
the case that the health care system and
society more broadly and in fact even
our our own selves very often really
fail people with a substance use
disorder
or an opioid use disorder because it
makes us uncomfortable it's something
that is stigmatizing uh that that people
are uncomfortable talking about um when
someone has cancer people uh reach in
and talk to that individual and tell
them to fight that cancer and you know
they're bringing casseroles and and
really leaning into the family and the
individual who's experiencing that
cancer event that doesn't really happen
with addiction it's very often the case
that people are left entirely alone to
work on these issues
and
that stigma can actually be lethal
we know that one of the reasons why
people don't seek help for a substance
use disorder particularly in opioid use
disorder is because of the self stigma
and fear of shame and stigma from family
and from treatment providers and and
that stigma can literally kill in that
instance because it's a barrier to
people getting their treatment
um nora volkov has said as you see here
it is incumbent upon clinicians to
address this and to meet the unique
needs of individuals and so we can't
just talk about using treatments that
work we have to talk about compassion
and the action it takes to get those
treatments out into the community
and make sure that everyone has equal
equitable access to the very best care
the other part of what i talked about in
our title is evidence-based treatment
and when i say that i mean treatment
that works
treatment rooted in science that's going
to help us give the very best
opportunity for a recovery from a
substance use disorder because the good
news is is that substance use disorders
are treatable um not everyone requires
treatment
people will go on to remit from a
substance use disorder on their own
that's not always the case
and it can be high risk
and so it's often very useful for people
to seek treatment i'm biased i believe
in treatment as a pathway
to recovery
but we have to get them there
so to start off i want to give you a
video and we'll watch this and then
we'll chat a little bit
i was using heroin for around six seven
years before
things started to catch up
i didn't know who i was
it just changes your brain chemistry and
it changes who you are so much
you know i was a little girl i was a
little girl and just a shell of myself
my name is sherry i grew up in
massachusetts i'm currently in school
for biomedical engineering
and i'm raising my seven-year-old
daughter
and we also have a dog
when i came into treatment there was
just so many pieces to work on
and you know i'm this tiny frail girl
and
i had never really learned any of the
skills needed to
to function in life
[Music]
i was scared
i was afraid to ask for help i was
afraid to talk to anybody
and
i've been fortunate all of the people
that i've worked with
from the front desk to
nurses and doctors
everyone has always treated me the same
[Music]
they've seen me change
i look nothing like i did before
i speak nothing like i did before you
know we
we change so much profoundly
and my nurses and my doctors
are right on board with that and
you know they always ask me like how's
school going how is this going you've
come so far remember when you were in
that shelter and now you're in this
house and you know you're doing such a
good job and it means so much um
sometimes we don't have people to tell
us that
so a couple of things about that video
um
to me
we don't need to talk about compassion
we actually need to do it and you could
hear in the words that sherry was
describing um that she met with
compassion no one no one in that
treatment system as she described it
said hello i'm going to give you
compassion um or i'm being compassionate
in doing this but embedded in the way it
was approached
was compassion it was breaking down
barriers it was helping on that journey
it was providing support and believing
that this individual
had the dignity
and the capacity
to affect their own recovery and the
change in this particular instance this
video is from pcss so the woman that you
saw was uh
receiving buprenorphine a medication
that's approved to treat opioid use
disorder
as part of her care
and as you heard her you also heard her
describing herself looking nothing like
she did before
so i would venture to guess that for
many of us if we had seen sherry as she
was presenting prior to her treatment
she would be
unrecognizable in some ways to us
relative to how she presents now but
that's
a good illustration
of how we make judgments and we
stigmatize people based on the symptoms
of their disease
rather than evaluating them as someone
deserving of care and having the
opportunity for treatment success
so a little bit about uh addiction and
substance use disorder in texas uh and
we it's very hard right now to think
about opioid use disorder and not really
think about it in the context of the
pandemic because unfortunately at a time
excuse me in our history when we are
spending a tremendous amount of
resources arguably not enough but much
more than we have previously to mitigate
the problems that we are seeing in the
united states with opioid use disorder
in 2020 we actually saw an increase in
an opioid related overdose deaths and a
concerning increase in deaths related to
methamphetamine as well
that's the wrong direction particularly
when um the public health infrastructure
of the united states is working actively
to reduce the number of overdose deaths
we saw them go up and and most people
would argue that in some ways that was
probably a result of existing factors
and failures but also a result of the
problems presented by the pandemic both
in terms of the restrictive access to
treatment in some areas as well as the
excuse me
as well as
this idea of social isolation
and other mental health issues that seem
to have emerged as a result of the
stress that people have been in during
the pandemic so i hope as i've been
talking you've been taking a look i'm
going to use texas as my example so
you'll see here these are the things
that i worry about the 1.65 million
texans who have a substance use disorder
alcohol or other drugs
the fact that one in ten people who need
treatment
only one in ten ever receive that
treatment and even fewer receive
evidence-based care that treatment that
i'm that works that i was talking about
earlier a lot of a lot of places offer
treatment
not as many offer treatment that's
rooted in science and based on the very
best evidence those clinical trials that
i was describing that i i learned as um
and conducted
in my career
and 75 000 additional deaths
have been attributed in the united
states that won't be counted in those
overdose deaths because these are
associated
with that including suicide and alcohol
use in the pandemic
[Music]
so what that leads us to believe and
this is a reporter alyssa klein talking
about the loss of her brother david um
recognizing the fact that in
that many of the losses um that we have
experienced as a as a country uh
will not be counted in the death toll of
the pandemic because these things
happened and this is the story of her
brother she's a reporter and he he
unfortunately died of an unintentional
opioid related poisoning
in 2020
to give a little bit more information
about this in the context of the
pandemic i just want to point this out
this is data that the centers for
disease control reported in 2020 of last
year and it was at the very beginning of
the pandemic and i want to point out a
couple things in that red box
this is a question related to whether or
not someone had started or increased
substance used to cope with pandemic
related stress or emotions so what we're
seeing there clinically is a functional
relationship between substance use and
managing stress and that really for me
as an addiction expert is is a concern
because that's when we start to see that
substance use starts to become um a
solution to stress and in some cases
particularly for individuals who go on
to develop a substance use disorder it
sort of begins to be the only tool in
the toolkit of coping
and that's really that insidious
setup for a substance use disorder and
i'll just point out one age group
between 18 to 24
24
1 in five reported starting to use or
increasing substance use to cope with
the pandemic that's not the type of
numbers that we want to see and it's one
of the concerning things that we have is
that perhaps as a result of the pandemic
over the next several years we'll see
substance use issues in the united
states getting worse so it won't be just
opioids it will be all substances and
we're starting to see early signals of
that now and that's the reason we're
doing some of our work
additionally i'm going to point out if
we look at that same survey and we look
at the characteristics by race and at
race and ethnicity i'll point out to you
that some groups seem to be
disproportionately using substances to
cope with stress
and these rates parallel some of the
issues we've seen with the pandemic in
terms of the disease burden of covet 19
as well so in my area i'm live in a
majority um hispanic community or latinx
community and here we see one in five uh
reporting using a substance to cope with
pandemic stress so this is the types of
things that we watch and we get
concerned about so i'm grateful to those
of you listening today to to think about
how we're going to be contending with
this moving forward
the other piece that's important is even
if we reject the notion that substance
use is a primary focus of our day-to-day
lives that we don't that's not really
something that interests us
if we're interested in other issues that
impact public health that impact our
social justice issues in the united
states we have to talk about substance
use disorder substance use
is proximal
in suicide we know that suicide a
completed suicide often has substance
use involved in that suicide completion
we know that
substance use increases the risk for a
sexually transmitted
infection including hiv and hepatitis c
we know that alcohol use for example
is a particularly common form a common
cause of cancer
and that's something that most people in
the united states simply don't know i'm
often
i go to cancer benefits as part of my
work and when when that comes up um you
can see people uh rethinking that glass
of wine and it's not to say that that um
all alcohol use is bad it's just for us
to understand and begin to have
conversations around the role of
substances
and its contributions to disease
uh criminal justice which is in danger
of becoming the de facto treatment
system for substance see in the united
states um
child
separation from family as a result of
substance use all of these things are
things that that weigh on us and so that
intersection between substance use
really places it at the crossroads of a
lot of public health issues beyond even
just mental health which is something
that we probably recognize more with
substance use
so
welcome
to be well texas
we're very glad that you're here
this is our program to address substance
use in texas
we have created a virtual community if
you will
a place where people can come and get
access to treatment
and any other positive change that they
see related to substance use uh for
themselves so we've created this vision
um to represent a different way of
talking about substance use that
welcomes people because we're very glad
when people call us we're so grateful to
be a part of the conversation that
they're going to be having with
themselves about what to do about
substance use when they recognize
there's a problem
and i'm going to tell you a little bit
more about our system of care that
begins with all of those grants
and funding that i started with
from the state of texas
so our mission is to expand equitable
access to evidence-based programs those
programs that work that are rooted in
science
that the best possible methods have
demonstrated
that this particular program or
intervention works it's grounded in
compassion rooted in science and another
novel piece of what we're doing
is that it's rooted in it's improved by
technology
so in our programs we include people
with lived experience of recovery these
are people who have or have used drugs
addiction metal medic addiction medicine
specialist behavioral health experts
like myself and health i.t innovators
all coming together to create be well
texas
in doing this i'm a scientist we are
creating a learning health care system
and the process behind this is that we
start with science
our research is influencing how we
practice and what we do
in our work
we are continuously evaluating our work
and adjusting the treatments that we
offer as a principle that underlines our
work
and then we share that work which is
part of the reason why i'm here today uh
talking about bewell texas and this
place that we've created
and so it's a continuous process of
improvement informed by the research
that we do
the model that we use is the
translational science benefits model so
again we don't just start programs we
actually apply the conceptual framework
around what we do this particular
model comes from
the field of translational science
a lot of work
has been done to address opioid use
disorder in the united states the
biggest public health failure related to
opioid use disorder in the united states
is that we failed to effectively
translate all of the innovations that we
know works all of those treatments that
we know are effective we failed to get
those into treatment programs and as a
result of that
people died
and so the work that we do is anchored
in this idea that we need to have
resources but we also need to engage in
science and the products of that science
and how we get them into practice are an
essential part of the work that we do so
in our team we have dissemination and
implementation experts implementation
scientists that help us with this and
study this but the work is always
focused on those four colored circles at
the end which are the benefits of
translational science it's impacting
clinical care it's impacting the
community it has economic impact and
that policy changes are associated with
the very best science being translated
into practice
we drilled down a little bit further so
on that previous slide you fought you
saw those four colored circles clinical
community economic and policy this is
our our organizing framework for what we
do and i want to point out that in that
interior circle is a framework for how
we actually get effective practices
that's that green circle and outside of
that is a yellow band or a yellow circle
encapsulating that maintenance so we
start at the center with this blue
circle in the center forgive me i don't
know if the pointer works we start in
the in the center here with the
evidence-based uh intervention
components and then we build on that
with these with these uh processes
health equity
costs and resources and capacity and
dynamic context and culture are all
critical to us being able to do this
work we want to make sure that the care
we offer is equitable that people have
an equal access um to this care
and that we're always pragmatic because
we understand that there are limited
resources with which to work
so this is our model by how we do that
and i'm going to show you
a little bit more so these are the
initiatives so all of those funding
programs that we we have
we
put into a set of
services that we identified as
complementing the existing ecosystem of
substance use in texas
and then we said where are the gaps what
do we need to do if we had
several million dollars or tens of
millions of dollars in this case close
to 100 million dollars what would we do
with that to have the biggest impact and
not take away from the existing
effective programs that already exist so
our project connects texans to
life-saving treatment
we have treatment networks both in the
outpatient level as well as
in the hospital setting
you'll also see that the second leg of
our virtual of our three-legged stool is
a virtual clinic so our first our first
leg is our treatment networks our
provider networks
then we also have a virtual clinic this
is a statewide clinic that anybody
regardless of their ability to pay even
without insurance can access so that
they can get treatment as close to on
demand as possible
and i'll talk a little bit more about
that in a minute we leverage technology
for this and then that third leg is
telementoring i can have a virtual
clinic that offers treatment to some i
can build a treatment network to offer
treatment to more but if we actually
mentor health care providers
physicians nurse practitioners um
physician assistants uh to to
treat substance use within their own
practices then we've really got
something because we have this network
of people that are willing to treat
and then we complement that with the
specialty care that we offer so i'll
show you a little bit about that
so our provider network
provider network here in this case uh is
a network that we've built over time
all of the treatments that we offer are
evidence-based treatment but we're not
doing that ourselves we're identifying
local communities local stakeholders and
local providers and contracting with
them to be able to provide the
treatments in that community
we're then providing them with the
training and technical assistance so
that they're better able to deliver this
care to the standards that we would want
to see to make this truly evidence-based
so in our technical assistance we
provide tools and resources and
strategies to help build that capacity
and then we're working on working with
them to have clinical process changes in
their workflows and how they work
to be able to do that we monitor all of
what we do there's an evaluation
backbone in this because the outcomes
are the most important thing we're
showing that by using evidence-based
practices programs can actually improve
the quality of care the program
efficiency and have better patient
outcomes
it's not hard to implement
evidence-based practice
the technical assistance is intended to
make it stronger
we
are building this network of providers
throughout texas because there are areas
in our community just like in all of the
united states that really have very
little access to service so we have
treatment deserts
and so these local networks help us to
bring that into the system and the
technical assistance ensures that those
folks are more comfortable engaging in
this treatment and treating opioid use
disorder because they have that
specialty technical assistance
and then the last thing we do with our
recovery support is our recovery support
services
in this we're actually utilizing
as we've mentioned earlier people with
lived experience peer recovery support
specialists are people in recovery who
are trained professionals in recovery
support
these is an entire workforce that's
being built in the united states
utilizing people that can can hold out
that hand
using a structured approach and be able
to complement what a healthcare provider
does a doctor really only sees a person
with a substance use disorder for their
clinical visits a peer recovery support
specialist
helps that individual
with the exoskeleton if you will
to be able to support what they're doing
in terms of their long-term recovery
people can put substances every day to
maintain
a change in your substance use requires
additional support because it's often
the case that when somebody changes
their use of substances the old networks
that they used to have the old
communities the places the people
can become challenging for them to deal
with if they're trying not to use
substances and so peers are people that
can help connect them to new ways it can
help address criminal justice issues it
can help
individuals get work again
and go to meetings and do other things
and so that's why we bring the peer
recovery support services as an
essential component of our provider
network
so right now we have four provider
networks we have our medication assisted
treatment or as i sometimes call it
medication for opioid use disorder or
medication for substance use disorders
right now we are providing services
through our network from for
evidence-based treatment for opioid use
disorder alcohol use disorder and we're
working on stimulant disuse disorders
based on some recent evidence that's
been published about the use of
medications to treat methamphetamine and
cocaine use disorder we have a hospital
network hospitals historically have not
been thought of as opportunities for
care and there's really a missed
opportunity there both in individuals
who are hospitalized and also people
presenting at the emergency department
those are moments of opportunity when an
individual is hospitalized and
identified as having an opioid use
disorder we should be providing them an
opportunity to begin their treatment to
initiate care for that opioid use
disorder and then finding them
opportunities and outpatient placement
that's easy that's simple that's not
complicated that provides warm links
and to care so that they're able to
continue that care the moment they get
out of the hospital so that's our
hospital network that we're building
right now and i'll show you some more
information on that we also have the
peer recovery support network that i
mentioned we have
the entire state of texas 254 counties
covered by 12 recovery support
specialist organizations that we
contract with that are able to provide
that support in that region
what's very exciting with that is we're
really working to utilize technology to
expand their reach particularly in
outlying areas where it's not as easy
for a peer to travel to meet an
individual and have a cup of coffee
to talk with them about plans so being
able to provide tele recovery or
recovery
using technological uh technological
solutions like the phone or a video chat
really can be a game changer in terms of
providing access and engagement
and then uh our emergency response hub
and i'll tell you a little bit about
that in a minute
so this is our recovery network through
texas you get a chance to see if you
haven't been to texas we are very large
state we have 254 counties some of those
counties do not have a physician
and so we are challenged when we do this
work to really understand how to be able
to build this network so we have
outpatient opioid use disorder treatment
offering buprenorphine as well as
injectable naltrexone those are two of
the three medications used to treat
opioid use disorder methadone being the
third
so we have 15 methadone providers
throughout the state of texas that are
providing this care all of this is for
individuals that would not otherwise be
able to get treatment texas does not
have medicaid expansion and as a result
of that
there are many individuals that do not
have the ability even through medicaid
to be able to access services and so as
a result we have people just without
insurance these funds pay for both the
medication as well as the medical visits
associated with that we have over 11
recovery support hubs that i mentioned
to you we also have um our disaster
programs uh that i'll mention to you in
just a minute and those are those seven
hubs in the blue and green and what i'm
trying to demonstrate with this is the
breadth um of what we're doing and what
we're trying to build because if we're
going to transform substance use
disorder and opioid use disorder in
texas we can't just do that from behind
a computer we need to get out into these
communities and this provider network is
really the backbone of that
this is an example of our partners we
have a very diverse set of partners
public and private organizations
for-profit non-profit
programs that have been in communities
for a very long time and some that are
standing up we have academic partners
using largely the ut system as well as
other universities in texas our medical
schools have been extraordinary partners
in this and this network is is to build
that tent because to address substance
use disorder for all the reasons that i
mentioned we need a really big tent and
we want to have as many partners
involved and funded by the work that
we're doing as possible
so i mentioned our hospital network
earlier and i wanted to give you a
couple examples about some of the work
in detail
what this hospital network does and we
have a program called shout that is
conducted in large part with the vision
of del seton medical center at ut system
in austin
this program
supports early intervention so it's an
opportunity when an individual with an
opioid use disorder is identified in a
hospital setting to be able to provide
them the opportunity to get access to
buprenorphine and so the teams that work
in the hospitals and i'm showing you an
example of the initial path of these
this is our first cohort
are trained to be able to provide
buprenorphine uh it is not complicated
sometimes with substance use we make
treatment so complicated that that in
and of itself is a barrier to actually
affecting change and so this is a simple
way to introduce
this level of care for opioid use
disorder just like a hospitalist in
hospital medicine would provide care for
anything else the individual started on
buprenorphine and then there is a
referral program so that these
individuals can have rapid access to
follow-up care in an outpatient
environment and that's the true measure
of success so you take the hospital that
moment when somebody is hospitalized as
a moment of opportunity and then move
from there so we have another new
program
that's one piece of it and it's great
that we're doing that but really as i
mentioned we need to have treatments uh
for all substance use disorders and
hospitals are almost opportunity moments
for more than
just opioids and so we have a new
program that we're starting this is a
screening brief intervention and
referral to treatment espert is the
acronym this is the idea that if you can
screen individuals
for a substance use disorder using very
brief screens that do not disrupt
clinical prayer
and provide them with appropriate
referrals when a substance use disorder
is identified that requires treatment um
that we're able to make those referrals
as well one of the exciting pieces about
this is that it's giving us an
opportunity to work in a pediatric
setting because a
substance use disorder and opioid use
disorder do not start at the age of 18.
it starts not even at the age of 16
sometimes it actually people's first
exposure to alcohol and other drugs um
is really quite uh young now in the
united states so it's not uncommon to
see individuals starting to use
substances in middle school and earlier
unfortunately
this program provides us an opportunity
to identify that in a hospital setting
for um in a pediatric hospital and then
provide referrals specifically tailored
to the needs of young people
this is a critically underserved
population in the united states
so the lessons that we learn from this
in our learning health care system we
will hope to be able to disseminate more
broadly
another project that you've seen on some
of the slides and this relates to that
second leg that virtual clinic that i'm
talking about was really the result of
an opportunity to respond to two
disasters
the first disaster was kovit
and the second disaster was some of the
hurricanes and coastal flooding that
texas unfortunately experiences from the
gulf so this is along the coast houston
north and south along the coast of texas
and so we sat there with this challenge
of trying to think about what would be
the thing that we would want to do with
several million dollars to be able to
help an area
or a region in the case of covid the
entire state in the case of hurricanes
and flooding the the coast of texas
along the gulf coast
what we identified was that the existing
infrastructure was struggling to meet
the demand for substance use disorder
services and so in this particular case
that this is talking about this was
along the coast
and we identified an opportunity and
said well we're going to do something
that complements what's already there
and then build something a little bit
bigger
and the result is our virtual
comprehensive services so this for those
familiar with a stepped care model is
somewhat similar to that and it begins
at the foundation which is a 24-hour
navigation hub and crisis support call
line
this call line and navigation hub is
web-based i'll show you the website in a
moment
what this does is it provides us with
the opportunity
to have a place for people to call if
they're concerned about drugs or alcohol
either for themselves or their family
the the line is staffed by those peer
recovery support specialists that i
mentioned to you earlier that the
backbone of what we do is having peers
involved and they're able both to talk
to somebody who's wondering if they're
having an issue
or perhaps has recently relapsed but
then they're also there to say hey are
you interested in treatment
one of the biggest barriers is again
finding treatment and so these
individuals are able to say well we can
connect you to our program
and they can receive
as close to on-demand as possible um
treatment
offerings directly from that so if you
imagine it it's a call
connected to triage connected to care
connected to visits and because it's
virtual an individual does not even need
to leave their home or the place where
they're calling from
this includes medication services as
well as the initiation of buprenorphine
for as long as we're allowed to do that
we're currently able to do that because
of some of the loosening of the
regulations around buprenorphine um so
we will start somebody um
on treatment for an opioid use disorder
if it's appropriate after thorough
evaluation
but low barrier we're able to do that
over the phone last week we had an
example where an individual called
um they
were appropriate for treatment with
buprenorphine for an opioid use disorder
but the physician at our clinic the
bewell texas clinic
felt like it probably needed another
person's eyes on them before they were
willing to do that so this individual
actually went to their primary care
doctor and said hey i have an addiction
medicine doc who wants to start me in
treatment can can i do that from your
office so that we're sure that it's safe
um and so it was a really great
partnership where someone that we'd
never met before um until that visit was
partnered with their primary care doctor
who again we'd never met before but
through consultation and liaison in a
video visit we were able to start that
person on life-saving treatment using
buprenorphine and again as a reminder
for those of you who may not know
the rate that this the
treatment initiation on buprenorphine
has an incredible impact um in reducing
morbidity and mortality associated with
opioid use disorder so it's a nice
example
in practice of what we're trying to
accomplish with this goal so that's that
treatment and care coordination piece
and then because of the pandemic and the
strain
that
that dealing with the pandemic has
placed on health care workers and the
stress that they've experienced we are
seeing an alarming increase in the use
of substances and mental health issues
among health care workers so we have a
particular carve out for specialized
peers
and services and treatment available for
health care workers as part of this
program as well
so this is the website for recovery
texas um we uh
we have this program um we're currently
staffed this is all very new we
currently start from 9 a.m to 9 00 p.m
and we're going 24 hours within the next
30 days and this is a place where people
are able to get help immediately and
have someone i'm speaking to them
chatting or
being able to communicate with them in
this in in real time
and then that
last
excuse me so this and then the third leg
in our third legged stool is that
telementoring so we are standing up a
telementoring institute to encourage
primary care providers
um
other specialties um to become involved
in treating substance use disorder um
and reducing the morbidity and mortality
and ending the overdose crisis or the
opioid crisis which is the name of this
meeting um by providing
appropriate mentoring and support and
specialty care consultation um for uh
those who who would be willing to treat
substance use disorder so this again is
a no-cost telementoring institute to
support improving treatment outcomes we
offer a practice-based culturally
responsive approaches to care
we
and the intent is to advance the quality
of care and the skills and competency of
healthcare workers broadly defined so
physicians to emf first responders
nursing staff medical technicians
behavioral health workforce to increase
access to substance use treatment so
that when these individuals come into
contact with someone with a substance
use disorder and opioid use disorder
they're able to respond with the very
best care and know that they've got
referral systems in place and the
complication liaison with experts and
opioid use disorders so these are
um a variety of activities that we do um
the the anchor platform for that is a
program that was developed out of the
university of new mexico called project
echo project
echo is a video based
mentoring consultation leads liaison
support service
it's hipaa compliant and it provides us
the opportunity to engage individuals so
in our programs we have a buprenorphine
community of practice where individuals
can join our mentoring program
there are twice monthly
community practice sessions where
didactics about getting started with
buprenorphine treatment or complex cases
for example we've had
conversations around treating hepatitis
c
in the context of opioid use disorder or
benzodiazepines and the co-use of
benzodiazepines and buprenorphine
boarded addiction medicine experts that
work with us are on these calls
and then the bulk of the conversation is
actually where someone who's part of our
community of practice a program
presents a case and that case is
discussed
and
feedback is given on that and then
question and answer so it's different
than just a didactic it's really about
that conversation around patients
it also helps to extend
supervision
of the work that people are doing and
provide
programs that would not otherwise have
access to this type of mentoring
outlying areas rural communities or
underserved communities with low access
this really is a way to do that
we also have a major get waiver campaign
for buprenorphine and then finally we
have our texas substance use symposium
which is dedicated to interprofessional
learning around improving access to high
quality evidence-based care for
substance use disorder
so one of the reasons uh that i got into
this work uh and working and partnering
with the state and really looking at
transformative change using science
is because at some point i just was
overwhelmed by the number of pictures of
parents holding pictures of their dead
children
these are all people including the woman
at the center from san antonio that i
met several years ago at international
overdose awareness day in august
in san antonio who lost her son
to
opioids and opioid poisoning
we have to do something differently we
have to keep centering conversations in
our country around substance use and the
incredible impact that it is having on
families and the quality of life of
people in all communities
particularly communities
of color
particularly in communities that are
rural and particularly in communities
that don't have the same access and
equitable care and quality of care
that others of us do in the united
states
so with that i will stop and i think i
am on time and we can maybe take a few
questions
thank you dr potter for that informative
presentation
and we will now start the live q a
portion of this webinar and if you have
any questions you want to ask please do
so now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far
left of your screen
so let's get started we already have
some great questions coming in
our first question
does
your use of the term evidence-based mean
that there are randomized control trials
yeah that's actually a really great
question um and so i'm so glad that it
came up i debated whether to put what i
mean by that so
evidence-based care
there are definitions of that it means
that yes you do use the best possible
evidence available
it's also informed by the clinician's
experience and the patient's experience
and their desire
and their desire and their outcomes so
it's patient-centric
and it's informed by
the science but it does have that piece
of the clinician as part of the
decision-making process unfortunately i
wish we had evidence-based practices or
evidence-based treatments for everything
to do with substance use and
unfortunately we just don't have that um
and you know any randomized controlled
trial
when you take it into the the one-to-one
experience between a patient
and a provider
are
is unique and so you need to be informed
by the science but you can't just let
randomized controlled trials rule
entirely there's also the importance of
practice based evidence what we learn
from clinical experience can be
extremely valuable um the challenge is
it's got to be informed by the
randomized controlled trials
thank you so much dr potter our next
question coming in does texas have a
mandatory treatment for s-u-d-o-u-d in
the prison system
hmm
so
not to my knowledge actually it's more
the case that there's a greater demand
in texas for treatment in the criminal
justice system then there is capacity to
serve it there is a program funded by
health and human services texas targeted
opioid response that is working in some
of the specialized prison systems to
expand access to medication one of the
things that underlies that question
that's unfortunate is very often when
someone enters the criminal justice
system they no longer have access to
their treatment um so somebody might be
taking methadone um they may be
incarcerated for a period of time and
then they don't have methadone anymore
and it actually creates a very dangerous
situation when that person is is
released
because they do not have
their particular risk for overdose and
unintentional opioid poisoning at that
time
because they no longer have the
physiological tolerance to higher levels
of opioids and unfortunately if they do
make a decision to use an opioid after
release they'll be at greater risk of
death um so no there is no mandate
um
so i think i think i answered that one
i was going to ramble about something
thank you so much and thanks to our
audience for these great questions would
you talk a little bit more about the
stigma impact substance use disorder
treatment
yeah so
you know stigma is a tough thing i can't
um emphasize enough
the
the impact
of historical stigma on substance use
disorders one of the most um
strange to use the word refreshing but
one of the most refreshing things that
i've seen actually since about 2016
was that we are increasingly having more
conversations around substance use um in
unexpected places um
uh
the the i i do not follow british
royalty but um i think it's prince
william's wife kate kate middleton
that's it kate middleton um just
recently put out a statement um and has
taken on talking about addiction as
something on on her platform that would
never have happened 15 years ago
in the 2016 election on both sides we
were having conversations um around
substance use uh and and impacting some
of the candidates lives and their
families um and i was watching college
game day a few weeks ago and ashton
kutcher was on there talking around
talking about alcohol and that it can
cause problems for some even though it's
it's he likes to drink so
it's
there's some hope that stigma
is starting to reduce
i don't necessarily take on stigma by
talking about stigma what we do in our
work is we just do things differently um
and that sounds glib but there's some
simple things that we can do um
in the way we treat people that will
destigmatize just naturally that's why
i said welcome
we're be well texas and we're so glad
you're here
because wherever people are we want to
meet them where they're at and we want
to treat them with respect and dignity
but stigma
affects us in three ways there's
societal stigma which we've talked a
little bit about
there's uh stigma
from self and then there's other people
stigma that they press upon you
and so we've even seen physicians who
want to treat opioid use disorder who do
not treat because they view the other
physicians in their practices would
judge them negatively for their
willingness to treat substance use
disorder so it has a huge impact um and
we just have to do things differently
thank you so much we have time for two
more questions would you comment on the
impact
of what we are seeing with opioid use
disorders and overdose on people with
chronic pain
yeah
so one of the unfortunate uh
things that has happened with our
increased concern around opioid use
disorder is that there's been um
supply-side solutions and so when i say
supply-side solutions i'm talking about
access to opioid analgesics so these are
those medications that can be diverted
but are actually prescribed to
individuals with chronic pain um in
response to their very real pain
many individuals with chronic pain have
seen a dramatic i've seen a cessation or
a dramatic reduction
in their access to opioids
it is true that the evidence for opioids
to treat chronic pain is mixed
but
the way that we have handled this in our
country using these supply-side
solutions really has had some fairly
dramatic unintended consequences that
have adversely impacted people with
chronic pain um they've been considered
speaking of stigma they've been treated
as if they have opioid use disorders
when they had no symptom of an opioid
use disorder they've been questioned uh
about their opioid use they've been
judged and they've lost access
much more rapidly than probably would be
appropriate
uh we are seeing some of the
consequences of that so as much as we
talk about uh how we do we address
opioid use disorder what we're not
talking as much about and i think this
is changing a little bit is how this has
impacted people with chronic pain there
are studies going on right now because
of heightened concern around suicide
an
escalation of suicide in individuals
with chronic pain
and one of the speculations is that may
be a result of the dramatic and rapid
cessation of access to opioids which
they had been using to treat their pain
thank you so much we have time for one
more question
as we accept this pandemic what do you
foresee will be the impact on substance
use and mental health
so as i alluded to
we are seeing some warning signs that
there has been a fairly significant
uptick in mental health and substance
use
problematic substance use
in the wake of the pandemic
some have gone so far as to say the next
wave of the pandemic is to uh is is the
mental health curve so we will see this
rapid escalation so some there's been
some coining of terms like flattening
the mental health and substance use
disorder curve
you know
people are extraordinarily resilient
um and uh
most people even with an increase in
substance use and even with
intermittent uh
issue with a mental health like an
escalation anxiety or depression or what
have you
most people will be okay
and that's a good thing
on the other hand
every life is valuable and precious and
we have to have the infrastructure and
we have to have the capacity
um to be able to serve all individuals
who are struggling with a mental health
or a substance use disorder
the lack of equity in care uh is just a
terrible issue the lack of parity um
that we are still seeing um in terms of
of people's ability to get mental health
and substance use disorder treatment
relative to physical health issues um is
significant uh and i i'm assuming that
the folks who took the time to join
today are at least curious about how to
mitigate that um but but i think it's
going to be
a while i we are concerned and we need
to be ready for the problems that are
coming because the the downstream
consequences could be additional deaths
in the wrong direction
absolutely dr potter thank you so much
for your presentation today would you
like to provide any closing remarks to
our audience before we go
so i i guess i just say thank you so
much um i do hope that people will think
of this not as an opioid crisis um that
they'll think about about this as um
a substance use crisis and also
work to better understand their own
personal relationships with substances
including alcohol in their lives and
approach this from a state of normal
behavior
and understand when normal
becomes problematic
we need resources and backstops for that
um
and try to do something differently uh
this this week or this month when you
run into someone um rather than judge
about substances and substance use maybe
think about a little bit different way
to approach it um in our own lives as
well within our professional life
it's wonderful well thank you so much
and again thank you for your important
research as well before we go i want to
thank our audience for joining us today
and for our interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand for two
years until october 2023 laborats will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time take care everyone stay safe
bye
you